al Primer Ministro peruano Alberto
tarola le ha disgustado que el
presidente de México Andrés Manuel López
Obrador haya dicho que Dina boluarte es
una presidente Usurpadora y legítima
tampoco le ha agradado que el presidente
de México Gustavo Petro haya dicho que
en Perú se produjo un golpe de estado a
Pedro Castillo es por eso que el Primer
Ministro peruano señaló que ambos
presidentes se encuentran atacando a
Perú y arremetido contra López Obrador y
Petro diciendo que ellos junto a Pedro
Castillo son caimanes que pertenecen al
mismo pozo y que sus políticas son
digamos de cierta manera eh acciones que
van en la mediocridad y también en el
autoritarismo
estas declaraciones del Primer Ministro
peruano Se realizaron el parlamento de
este país al que acudió para pedir que
se modifique la ley para que la
presidenta Dina boluarte que no cuenta
con vicepresidentes en este momento que
la puedan reemplazar cuando ella salga
al exterior se le otorgue esta facilidad
para que boluarte pueda defender los
intereses a la presidencia y también de
esta nación andina cuando surjan este
tipo de situaciones en el extranjero
Bueno y cómo quedan entonces las cosas
respecto a la alianza del Pacífico
precisamente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
se niega a entregarle a Perú la
presidencia pro tempore del organismo
diversos especialistas están señalando
que Andrés Manuel López Obrador está
incumpliendo y está violando convenios
internacionales y que por ahora México
ejecuta una presidencia de facto del
organismo regional y que la alianza del
Pacífico se está desenvolviendo mediante
secretarías técnicas Andrés Manuel López
Obrador también ha dicho que
decidirá si tal vez le entrega la
presidencia del organismo a México o
perdón a Colombia o chile y que estos
países decidan qué es lo que va a
suceder la alianza del Pacífico fue
iniciada por México Colombia chile y
Perú como un organismo para impulsar la
economía a la integración de los duelos
y es por eso se critica que la
integración es la que ha quedado
paralizada